♪ ♪
>> Greg: SOMETIMES THE TRUTH
COMES FROM THE MOST SURPRISING
PLACES.
LOOK WHAT JUST CAME OUT OF THE
MOUTH OF AN OLD SOCIALIST.
BERNIE SANDERS SO THE DEMOCRATS
FELT LIKE JOE BIDEN AS A NOMINEE
WOULD MAKE THE SAME BLUNDER WITH
HILLARY.
REMEMBER SHE LOST ON THEM BLIMP
THE RUSSIANS AND THEN WANDERED
IN THE WOODS FOR A MONTH.
HE STARED WITH HILLARY, HE VOTED
FOR NAFTA AND
NORMALIZE TRADE RELATIONS WITH
CHINA AND THE WAR IN IRAQ.
THESE POSITIONS SAY BERNIE WON'T
RALLY YOUNG PEOPLE, WORKING
PEOPLE OR PEOPLE OF COLOR.
HE IS SAYING THAT THE WINNING
CANDIDATE SHOULD BE AGAINST
NAFTA, BE AGAINST NORMALIZE
TRADE IN THE WAR IN IRAQ.
IF THAT IS THE CASE THEN HE JUST
ENDORSED TRUMP FOR A SECOND
TERM.
AMAZING.
I GET IT, HE THOUGHT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT HIMSELF.
HE ADMITTED HE WANTS WHAT TRUMP
SAID HE WANTS.
BERNIE AND CASEY WERE NAPPING,
HE ALREADY BLEW UP NAFTA AND HE
HAS CHALLENGED
CHINA AND HE HAS ANNOUNCED WARS,
I'M SURE HE MAY BE CASTING
HIMSELF AS THE OUTSIDER LOOKING
TO UNSEAT THE ESTABLISHMENT, BUT
HE IS WAY TOO LATE.
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS THE IMPACT
OF LEFT WING LIBERALS AT AOC AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
BOARD.
THEY ARE ALREADY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WHAT IS NEXT FOR BERNIE?
MAYBE TERRORIZING THE BRIDGE,
LAUGHING OFF THE E.U.
I HAVE A PLAN THAT SHOULD SAVE
HIM SOME TIME, MONEY, AND
EFFORT.
ENDORSED TRUMP AND DROPOUT.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT.
>> Juan: I LIKE THAT ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT WAS INVENTIVE.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
DON'T YOU SEE THE OVERLAP?
AGREE ON MORE THINGS THAN THEY
DISAGREE.
I SAID THAT PARTY SUPPORTERS ARE
A MERE IMAGE.
YOU COME TO THIS POINT IN A
POPULIST METAL UNSIGNED LEAVES,
FALL WITH BERNIE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN SO MANY OF THE
LEFTISTS WERE I FOLLOWED WITH
TRUMP.
IT'S THAT LINE.
WHAT IS INTERESTING TO ME IS
THAT I THINK YOU LOOK AT THE CNN
POLL AND YOU SEE THAT BIDEN IS
MAINTAINING EITHER MID TO LOW
LET'S SAY, WHAT YOU SEE FROM
BERNIE IS THAT HE IS FADING.
I THINK THIS IS A STRATEGY TO
GET BACK IN THE GAME.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ LAST
WEEK SAID WITH REGARD TO CLIMATE
CHANGE, YOU CAN'T JUST DO MIDDLE
GROUND AND BEAT TROUT.
YOU CAN'T GO BACK TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
BERNIE COMING OUT SAYING, THE
SAME THING, HE HAS ESTABLISHMENT
AND IF YOU THINK THAT HE IS
EXCITING YOU ARE WRONG, YOU ARE
REPEATING HILLARY.
>> Greg: IT'S INTERESTING, WE
WERE ALWAYS CRITICAL OF TRUMP
PRECISELY FOR THE THINGS THAT
BERNIE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
WE ARE FREE TRADERS.
>> Dana: FOR EXAMPLE BERNIE
WOULD SAY, WE WOULD NEVER DO
ANYTHING TO TOUCH ENTITLEMENT
SPENDING.
WE WILL GET RID OF TRADE.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THERE WERE
SOME PEOPLE.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME
DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE LIKE IN
MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN, THEY VOTED
FOR OBAMA BUT THEN VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
THAT WAS BECAUSE IF THE
CANDIDATE HAD BEEN
BERNIE SANDERS THEY MIGHT HAVE
VOTED FOR BERNIE, TO SEE WHAT I
MEAN?
DO YOU FOLLOW?
LISTEN TO SOMETHING TODAY THAT I
HAVE TO RECOMMEND.
LESS AND 1.5 SPEED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS A
PODCAST CALLED THE ARGUMENT AND
THEY TAKE AN ISSUE IN A DEBATE
BOTH SIDES AND YOU CAN DECIDE ON
YOUR OWN HOW YOU FEEL.
TODAY'S WAS ABOUT SOCIALISM
VERSUS LIBERALISM.
IT WAS THE INTRAMURAL FIGHT.
IT WAS INTERESTING, THE GUY HE
WAS REPRESENTING SOCIALIST, THE
MANAGER, HE SAID WE THINK BERNIE
WILL GET ALL THE WAY UP THERE
AND HE WON'T WIN SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THEN IT WILL SUPPORT BIDEN.
IT'S LIKE ALL OF THIS IS FOR
WHAT?
>> Greg: WHAT DOES IT FOR?
WHAT IS LIFE ABOUT?
>> Emiyl: AT THE MOMENT OUR
ENTERTAINMENT.
I THINK THAT THE DEMOCRATS
OBVIOUSLY THINK BIDEN IS GOING
TO WIN.
HE THINK HE IS THEY WANT AND
THAT IS THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
THAT IS WHY BERNIE'S BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IS CONVINCING THEM
THAT HE CAN BEAT TROUT.
HE IS NOT WILLING HOWEVER TO
SACRIFICE HIS IDEAS, AS FAR LEFT
IDEAS SO THAT THOSE IN THE
MIDDLE WON'T BACK HIM AND
BIDEN'S BIGGEST CHALLENGE AT
THIS POINT IS CONVINCING VOTERS
THAT HE IS NOT JUST HILLARY 2.0
ALTHOUGH HE HAS COME FARTHER
THAN SHE IN THAT REGARD.
BOTH OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
CONVINCE VOTERS THAT THEY ARE
THE WHOLE PACKAGE BUT I THINK
BIDEN IS IN IT FOR THE LONG CON
AND BERNIE IS ONLY FOCUSED ON
THE PRIMARY.
I THINK THE PACKAGE TODAY WAS
HIM TRYING TO SAY TO THE FAR
LEFT, I HEAR YOU AND I HAVE NOT
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ LISTEN TO THIS
POLICY.
I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
>> Greg: THE PROBLEM IS THAT
BIDEN OVERALL IS PROBABLY A
BETTER PACKAGE, BUT BERNIE IS
THE MORE INTERESTING PACKAGE AND
HAS MORE ENERGY.
>> Juan: HE IS ALSO THE ONE
WHO IS WILLING TO MAKE CHANGES.
THE PROBLEM AS A FORMER OBAMA
VOTER, THE PROBLEM I SEE --
>> Greg: YOU VOTED FOR OBAMA?
TAKE HIM AWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE HAS THE HOPE.
TRUMP HAS THE MESSAGE, THEY ARE
DESTROYING EVERYTHING.
THEY ARE TEARING THE COUNTRY
APART.
WHAT BERNIE IS DOING IS THE
IDENTITY POLITICS ASPECTS.
HE WANTS SWEEPING CHANGE, HE
DEMONIZES PEOPLE ON A DAY-TO-DAY
BASIS AND THOSE OBAMA VOTERS
THAT HE COULD PICK UP, HE HAS
ALREADY MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE HE HAS
CONTINUED SAYING THOSE PEOPLE
ARE THE PROBLEM.
NOT WASHINGTON, THOSE PEOPLE ARE
THE PROBLEM.
IF YOU WANT TO GET THOSE PEOPLE
YOU HAVE TO REACH OUT TO THOSE
PEOPLE.
HE IS NOT WILLING TO COMPROMISE.
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN WHO IS THE
SAME OLD GUY AND YOU BERNIE
WANTS TO MAKE SWEEPING CHANGES,
BUT THE VOTERS THAT THEY NEED HE
HAS NOT WILLING TO GO AFTER.
>> Juan: WHAT STRIKES ME AS I
AM LISTENING TO YOU, SO MUCH OF
THE BIDEN SUPPORT COMES FROM
BLACK VOTERS, IT'S OVERWHELMING.
>> UNTIL THE GENERAL ELECTION.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
THEY ARE VERY UPSET.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY WILL VOTE
FOR THE REPUBLICANS, BUT THEY
WILL STAY WELL.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT
SANDERS HAS DONE WELL WITH BLACK
VOTERS AND I THINK THAT HE NEEDS
TO COME ANYBODY NEEDS TO WANTS
TO OVERTAKE JOE BIDEN.
DOES THE PLUG SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
THAT?
ONE FINAL NOTE, THE FIGHT
BETWEEN BERNIE AND JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO GET UGLIER AND WORSE
THIS MONTH AS WE APPROACH THE
FIRST DEBATE.
THAT IS WHERE THEY HAVE TO TAKE
DOWN BIDEN BITE INTO THIS BIG
LEAD.
>> Greg: DO KNOW IT IS IN THIS
NEW GREENDALE?